- We literally sat back
and watched him
not wanna hold the jersey,
not wanna put the hat on.
- "You go there, you run there,
Hey, dadgum it, I'm gonna
get you down there in the flat."
- Brady, Brady, Brady!
♪♪♪
- Hello, and welcome, everybody,
to Gillette Stadium
in Foxborough, Massachusetts.
The locker rooms are bugged
the sidelines
are being recorded.
It's Cheaterville 2018.
I'm Jets homer Adam Lefkoe,
joined as always
by Patriots fanboy
Christopher Simms.
- That's right.
The AFC East champs
14 out of the last
15 years there, slugger.
When's the last time you won it?
Ah, who cares?
The "AFC Least" is what you are.
- Mo Lewis knocked out
Drew Bledsoe
in comes Tom Brady.
You're welcome!
Belichick learned from Parcells.
- Don't say "you're welcome."
- We built your franchise.
- Belichick didn't wanna work for you guys.
- He couldn't handle it.
- 24 hours,
and he had enough there.
And, hey, thanks for
Darrelle Revis, too.
We won a Super Bowl with him.
Appreciate that.
You're kinda
like our farm team.
You're a Triple-A system for us
New England Patriots.
- Moo!
Speaking of being on the farm:
Out to pasture, Tom Brady.
Almost time for him
to be forced to retire
with the way he's playing.
Don't know about it.
My California quarterback
is young
and still has muscle definition.
- Oof. Kind of embarrassing
when you're losing
to a 41-year-old
quarterback once again.
- Mmm, all I know is we have
more Pro Bowlers than you.
- Oh, and, hey, start livin' off
that Joe Namath era
a little longer.
1960—oh, who cares?
That was forever ago.
Close the yearbook,
and try to win something recent.
- There's only one thing
we can agree on.
- What's that?
- Why the hell did Tom Brady
kiss his kid that long?
- Cuz he's the G.O.A.T.,
and he's—
- Wait, you approve of this kiss?
- He's the D.O.A.T., the greatest
Dad of All Time. Deal with it.
Brady, Brady, Brady, Brady,
Brady, Brady, Brady!
His rookie year I knew
he was a baller
because he was lettin'
our sideline know
how much money he
had in the bank already.
He was lettin' us know
he was the man
cuz he's a top-10 pick,
right?
- What'd you go? 8?
- Yeah, I went 8.
- How was draft for you?
- Yeah, that's what
I wanna hear, the draft.
The lead-up to that.
- Draft was amazing, man.
- Yeah, 2004, the draft.
- Yeah, 2004,
and that was back when
you know, they only took
about the top five guys.
You know, I'm in the room
with guys like Eli Manning
who's supposed
to be No. 1 overall
and Big Ben and Robert Gallery.
And I'm like, "Dude, I don't
care if I sit in that green room
and I am the last one.
I want to share
in this experience."
And, you know,
we had a running joke, like
"Who's gonna be
the last guy drafted?"
And, you know, I wasn't upset.
I said, "I'm gonna be
the last one.
I know I'm goin' 10 to Houston."
So everyone kinda
has their own table.
When you haven't been drafted
you're sitting back
watching this unfold.
- Right.
- And so, yeah
with Eli, San Diego drafts him—
- Yes, they did.
- Before they actually
figure out the trade.
We literally sat back
and watched him
not wanna hold the jersey,
not wanna put the hat on.
He's just in there, pissed.
And so as the draft's
kinda goin' on
guys are gettin' called,
guys are gettin' called.
Me and Ben are last,
and I'm just thinkin', you know
"All right, Ben's gonna go"
and I had actually went
to the bathroom
and then I hear my name, "8."
And, you know, as I'm hugging
my mom and kissing her
and dappin' up my brothers
and stuff
I just kind of look over at Ben
and, like, "I guess you last."
You know, just kinda,
kind of a running joke
to this day, but—
- Ah, that's awesome.
- Heck, he probably went
in the best spot
because he has two rings,
he went to a great defense
great organization and so—
Everything happens for a reason,
but I was not the last one
even though all week long
that's all we joked about.
- So DeAngelo Hall got to point
at Big Ben
and go, "Guess you last."
- Yeah.
- And Big Ben totally went
to the perfect situation.
- Well, I mean, gosh. I mean,
"Guess you last" in the top 12
is not that demeaning, like—
- Unbelievable.
- "Oh, guess you're last.
You have to get picked
in the top 10."
- I remember Eli, Philip and Ben
being drafted
and it was an amazing
pre-draft debate.
You had this guy
from North Carolina State
with a weird release angle.
- Right.
- You had Archie's other son
in Eli.
- Yep.
- And you had Big Ben.
- Yeah.
- Comin' from the MAC,
ready to tear it up.
- Right.
- As we look at their careers—
- Yeah.
- How do you
stack them up now?
- To me, Ben Roethlisberger
is the best one of the bunch.
- Mmm.
- I mean, Ben Roethlisberger,
I think, is a truly great talent.
I think he's borderline top-10
quarterback of all time.
He was a little bit,
like, indefensible at times
because he had that ability
to scramble around the pocket.
- Think about all the years
we saw Big Ben
with a defender on him
and still bein' like,
"You know what?
No, no, I'll still
throw it 40 yards."
- Exactly right.
He's a great
down-the-field thrower.
He could play in any offense
so I do look at him as being
the best one on the field.
- Philip was the best self-OC.
- Whoa.
Philip is the, like—
- "You go there, you run there.
Hey, dadgum it, I'm gonna
get you down there in the flat."
And he had the most kids,
which is incredible.
- And he's yellin'
at the coaches.
Like, yeah.
Philip's, like, a must-watch.
- Yes.
- I mean, when you see him
on the field in the few times
I got to play against him
or at least be on the sidelines
and watch him—
- Yeah.
- The fire from him
you can feel it on the field.
- Mmm.
- Yes, it's—
All three are awesome.
All three are gonna be in
the Hall of Fame conversation.
- I don't know what
to say about Eli.
- Eli had two great playoff runs
and two great
Super Bowl performances.
I would say his regular-season
career has been below average.
- In your heart of heart—
I'm gonna put you
on the spot like Booger.
- Right.
Whoa.
- Is Eli—
- Am I Jason Witten?
- Is—
I don't know.
Is Eli a Hall of Famer
in your heart?
- In my heart, no, Eli is not a Hall of Famer.
- But he's gonna get in.
- And I know
that's gonna make waves.
Listen, I'm not tryin'
to hate on Eli Manning.
I know him.
- I agree.
- My dad's Phil Simms—
- Don't make this a Phil thing.
- And Eli Manning's the greatest
quarterback in Giants history.
I got that.
I don't care.
I do not think Eli Manning
is a Hall of Famer.
I think he's an all-time great,
but not a Hall of Famer.
- You know, he does pass my one
Hall of Fame rule, though.
- What?
- Can you tell the story
of the NFL without him?
And I don't think
you can, though.
- Yeah, well, OK.
- That's the problem
because of those two runs.
- Cuz of the two Super Bowls.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I hear you.
There's other—
- Yeah.
- Jim Plunkett won two
Super Bowls.
He's not in the Hall of Fame.
- All I ask is
the Manning family
please don't have us hurt.
Like, please.
- Oh, they're gonna send
a hitman out to us?
- Yeah. Please.
Like, you guys are great.
You guys are great.
Please, I was only kidding.
Ple—no, but seriously.
- What's up? This is Denzel Ward,
and you're watching
"Simms & Lefkoe" on
Bleacher Report.
- All right, baby, let's finish
this season strong.
You know which newsstand
we're goin' to.
Final pick of
the regular season.
Allie, be that oracle.
It is not about the destination.
It is about the journey.
But our current destination:
the final regular-season game
"Somebody & Lefkoe."
The Cowboys head to New York
to take on the Giants
and I wore
this nice shirt for you.
- What is this, velvet?
- Yeah.
- Oh, man.
- No, it might actually be.
Very expensive!
I feel like you're not
a big Cowboys fan.
- Not at all.
- No.
- Hate?
- Not at all.
- That's what I'm feelin'.
- Wow.
- I don't like the word, but when
it comes to the Cowboys—
and the Eagles—same thing.
- Just unnecessary digs
from this guy.
Giants, they're fighting for pride.
- OK.
They're fighting for Shurmur's
second year, I suppose.
- Yeah.
- What do you think?
- I hate to say it—
- You're goin' Cowboys.
- Got to.
- You don't think Eli's gonna
go out there
and make a few guys miss,
maybe break a tackle?
- I think Ezekiel will make
a few guys miss before Eli.
- Oh my God.
All right, so Cowboys.
- Yes, Cowboys.
-Good regular season.
- Yes, sir.
Hopefully
I'll see you next year.
- Yeah.
Or maybe—
- In the playoffs.
- The playoffs.
Allie, let me produce the show.
- [Laughing]
- OK?
Allie went against his fandom.
He's takin' the Cowboys.
- Man, no loyalty in that guy.
I'll tell you, I mean, just—
He'll just throw his team away
in a heartbeat.
- We agree, though.
- We do agree, yeah.
I mean, Dallas is playin'
for something.
They wanna get into the playoffs
on the right foot.
- I'm more interested
in the quarterback situations
for next season.
- Right.
- I know the Cowboys still have
some playoffs ahead of them.
But the Cowboys' situation
with Dak—
- Yeah.
- You have a number in your head
because he's gonna be
a free agent
that you just can't pay him more
if you want this team
to continue to grow.
- Right. Well, he's not gonna be
a free agent
but he's eligible to get
the new contract, right?
- Gotcha.
- So that's the first thing.
- And they—they're gonna give it to him.
- I would imagine yes.
- But yours is around, like,
the 18, 20s.
The Andy Daltons, the Matt—
not the Matt Staffords anymore.
- But somewhere in there.
- Yeah.
- I mean, yes, the—
the high teens, low 20s.
They, they should not let him
hold them hostage
for $28 million a year
Matt Ryan-,
Aaron Rodgers-type money.
- No.
- No way, negative, Ghost Rider.
- Because if you give him
that money, it takes away
that nickel corner.
- Right.
- It takes away
that backup tight end.
- People on your roster,
exactly right.
- The problem, though, is if you
look around the league—
- Yeah.
- What are the best options?
- You've come up with the best
options, and they're not bad.
I just don't think Cowboys
fans would be happy.
- I would agree.
They're not gonna excite people.
And, hey, listen, some things
could also happen
that I don't foresee.
I mean, will Ryan Tannehill
definitely be in Miami?
- Interesting.
- I don't know.
- But who are the names?
- All right.
Joe Flacco.
Let's—for one
we know he's gonna be
on the outs in Baltimore.
- Meh.
- I know, I hear you,
but he did win a Super Bowl,
and I still think
you can win with him.
Teddy Bridgewater, OK.
- People get very excited about
Teddy Bridgewater.
- They definitely do. Andy Dalton
could be on the outs.
- Not gonna sell him.
- You're not gonna sell him?
OK.
- No.
Cowboys fans are gonna go,
"I want Dak back."
- OK, and then what
about Jameis Winston?
- They're gonna—
- Mmm!
That's a tough one.
- No, it's more I—
- His talent can
excite you, though.
His talent can excite you.
- No, not—
- But I hear you.
OK.
So that, that's fine.
- I'm curious
about Eli, though.
- Yeah.
- Because now we're in
a situation where it seems like
they wanna go into 2019—
Is there another option there?
I, as an Eagles fan,
hope they go into 2019 with Eli.
- Whether they bring him back
or not
they need to draft
a quarterback
whether that's to sit behind Eli
for a year or to be the guy.
We know rookie quarterbacks
can go to the playoffs.
We've seen it.
Joe Flacco did it.
- Ugh.
- Russell Wilson did it.
Oh, wait. Dak Prescott, the
guy we were just talking about?
His rookie year, they were
the No. 1 seed in the NFC
so it's not
the old days anymore.
- I want the Giants
to start Eli forever.
- Stop talking meanly
about my Giants.
- For Simms—
- Peace out, homies.
- I am the L-E-F-K-O-E.
- Eagles fan.
- That's for damn sure.
We will holla, holla,
holla atcha later.
Enjoy the games.
We have this young quarterback
from California.
- Right.
- You might get some
youth in that lineup.
- I don't know, that guy
seems a little immature.
He dressed up as Santa Claus
on some stupid show last week.
- Really? What show was that?
- Yeah, Simms and Lefkoe.
- Never heard of it.
- Not a good show.
- Anyway–
Bill Parcells taught
Bill Belichick.
You're welcome!
We built your franchise.
- Well, I mean,
Parcells didn't, uh—
S--t.
- Got him.
Peace, bro.